Boa noite minhas amigas meus amigos para
mais uma live vamos discutir aqui alguns
assuntos e depois responder à dúvidas de
vocês ao
vivo Deixa primeiro eu acessar aqui o
arquivo das
perguntas aqui perguntas
pronto deixar pronto
aqui bem pessoal primeira coisa que eu
queria discutir com vocês é que existia
uma suspeita que Esses medicamentos para
emagrecimento ficaram
muito ficaram muito populares nos
últimos anos né o ozen pique e antes
dele a liraglutida
né tinha uma suspeita que Esses
medicamentos
eles induziam ao suicídio tá então saiu
um artigo recente dizendo que o
regulador de medicamentos da União
Europeia não encontrou evidência
suficiente de que uma classe de
medicamentos para diabetes perda de peso
como imensamente popular
e egov da novo nordisk que eles estariam
ligados a pensamentos
Suicidas então o comitê de avaliação de
risco de fármaco vigilância que monitora
os efeitos colaterais de medicamentos
Boa noite Adriana diz que nenhuma
atualização foi necessária para a
informação do
produto dos tratamentos após revisar as
evidências Então por conta disso as
ações da farmacêutica na Marquesa novo
nordisk subiram mais de
2% Então essa conclusão surge depois que
a ema esse órgão europeu ter aumentado
em dezembro a sua revisão a classe de
medicamentos para perda de peso o
Diabetes conhecido como agonista G lp1
né como é o caso doque e da
liraglutida para OB ter mais dados
fabricant de medicamentes para
investigar mais a fundo esse problema
então essa análise começou em Julho
depois que o regulador de saúde da
Islândia sinalizou três casos de
possíveis suicídios ligados esse
medicamento
então a revisor sem trouxe medicamentos
que contém semaglutida né que em pique a
liraglutida né que é o
saxenda ambos esses dois tipos de
remédios são direcionados a
glp1 a liraglutida Como eu disse é o
ingrediente ativo do SAC senda enquanto
que a semaglutida é o ingrediente ativo
doque e do
Então esse órgo europeu analisou os
resultados de um grande estudo realizado
nos Estados Unidos e não encontrou uma
associação entre o uso de semaglutida e
pensamentos
Suicidas os resultados de um outro
estudo conduzido pela mesma Associação
lá europeia também não deu suporte uma
ligação entre Esses medicamentos dessa
classe glp1 e risco de pensamento
Suicidas então ambos os estudos foram
com base em registro eletrônico de
saúde certo então as primeira notícia
que eu queria falar para vocês
aqui vamos pra segunda
notícia bem Pessoal vocês sabiam que o
taiuan pode ser mais eficaz do que o
exercício aeróbico para reduzir a
pressão arterial em adultos com
pré-hipertensão boa noite elía Cristina
Eliane Carlos um estudo recente comparou
os efeitos de 12 meses da prática de
taii versus exercícios aeróbicos em 342
adultos chineses com pressão arterial no
limite e o que os pesquisadores
descobriram foi
surpreendente como ta então reduziu a
pressão arterial sistólica em 7 MM de
mercúrio comparado a 4,6 MM de mercúrio
nos exercícios aeróbicos ou seja o taix
x reduziu mais a pressão do que os
exercícios
aeróbicos vamos discurtir também além
dessa questão de o taixi ter reduzido
mais a pressão
arterial do que exercício físico quais
seriam os outros benefícios extras para
saúde cardiovascular que esse estudo eh
descobriu E por que essa antiga arte
marcial chinesa pode ser uma excelente
opção para quem busca uma atividade de
baixo Impacto para melhorar a saúde do
coração deixa eu tirar esse barulhinho
aqui do WhatsApp que eu não gosto disso
aqui
pronto vamos
continuar vamos também contextualizar os
achados com outras evidências
científicas sobre os mecanismos por trás
dos efeitos que o tax xuan pode baixar a
pressão
arterial Então vamos estudar melhor o
que que foi verificado vamos verificar
melhor o que foi estudado então para
entender os efeitos do Tai xuan na
pressão arterial os pesquisadores da
China realizaram um estudo randomizado
controlado com 342 pessoas adultos de
idade eh média que tinha um
pré-hipertensão pré hipertensão é aquele
estado intermediário que a pessoa ainda
está desenvolvendo uma pressão alta
pressão sistólica está entre 120 a 139 e
a diastólica tá entre 80 e 90 ainda não
é hipertensão mas tá muito próximo da
Hipertensão e já aumenta os riscos
cardiovasculares então durante 12 meses
um grupo praticou o taixi e o outro fez
exercícios aeróbicos como caminhada
rápida e ciclismo ambos quatro vezes por
semana por 60
minutos os pesquisadores mediram a
pressão arterial no consultório e com
monitor ambulatorial de 24 horas no
início com 6 meses e com 12 meses também
avaliar outros fatores de risco
cardiometabólicos qualidade de vida e
efeitos
adversos o estilo de taii praticado foi
o yang de 24 movimentos os exercícios
aeróbicos foram realizados com uma
intensidade 55 a 70% da frequência
cardíaca máxima algumas sessões foram em
grupo e outras individuais algumas
supervisionadas e outras registradas
pelos
participantes após um ano tanto o taii
quanto os exercícios aeróbicos reduziram
a pressão arterial sistólica que é
aquela
maior mas o taii foi mais eficaz Então
vamos aos números do Taxi reduziu a
pressão sistólica em 7 MM de mercúrio e
quant os exercícios aeróbicos reduziram
em 4,6 mm de mercúrio que foi uma
diferença de
2,4 a mais pro taixi na pressão
diastólica ambos tiveram reduções
similares aos 6 e 12 meses no
monitoramento ambulatorial Taisi reduziu
mais a pressão sistólica de 24 horas e
também mais a noturna
nemhum outro desfecho Foi diferente
entre esses dois
grupos então aos 6 meses o taii já havia
reduzido a pressão histórica em 6,2 mm
de mercúrio versus 4,9 dos aeróbicos 31%
do grupo de taii atingiu a pressão
arterial
ideal que é abaixo 120 por 80 ao final
comparado a 22% do grupo aeróbico e
menos participantes evoluíram para
hipertensão com
12% verso
18% então para entender melhor esses
resultados vamos olhar o que que a
ciência já sabe sobre o taii e pressão
arterial então outras Pesquisas mostram
uma meta análise com 24 estudos já havia
mostrado que o taxi melhora a pressão
sistólica diastólica além de vários
domínios de qualidade de vida outra
metanálise com 126 estudos Esse é bem
grande hein apontou Tai como uma das
intervenções não farmacológicas mais
eficazes para reduzir a pressão embora a
qualidade das evidências era considerada
baixa então se acredita que a razão do T
baixar a pressão arterial é que ele
modula o sistema nervoso autônomo
aumentando a atividade parassimpática
meditação deve ter o mesmo efeito né mas
esse tudo não é sobre meditação Então
esse aumento da atividade parassimpática
ajuda a baixar a pressão também tem
evidência de que que o taixi reduz um
hormônio que constringe os vasos que a
jun temina dois inclusive vários anti
hipertensivos atuam sobre esse hormônio
angiotensina então aumenta uma
substância que dilata que o óxido rí
precisa desbloquear
Anes Então ta tipul envolver posturas
estáticas
isométricas a os exercícios isométricos
que têm se mostrado os mais eficazes
para pressão
arterial Então as evidências acumulam de
que vários tipos de exercício não só o
aeróbico pode beneficiar pressão
arterial e o taix se destaca como opção
eficaz prazerosa e acessível então se
você tem ou conhece alguém com
pré-hipertensão ou
hipertensão considere praticar o
taxi reduzir sua pressão melhorar sua
qualidade de vida diminuir os seus
riscos cardiovasculares e mesmo se a sua
pressão é normal o taii é uma excelente
forma de manter controlada e ainda
trazer outros benefícios para sua saúde
física e mental né então é importante
procurar um instrutor qualificado para
aprender a técnica correta você pode
praticar também em casa por
conta Existem vídeos e aplicativos que
ensinam as
sequências então a conclusão é que o uma
arte marcial antiga que continua
demonstrando paraa saúde a luz da
ciência moderna embora ainda precisemos
de mais estudos com mais qualidade as
evidências apontam e sugerem fortemente
que essa prática pode ser uma liada
valiosa no controle da pressão
arterial então é interessante
experimentar o taixi
tá o próximo artigo é sobre a
desnutrição e uma tentativa de recuperar
os solos que estão depal perados de
nutrientes através de adição de
micronutrientes tá então acho que você
sab que a desnutrição afeta boa parte da
população mundial e se eu dissesse para
vocês que a fertilização de culturas com
micronutrientes pode ser uma solução
promissora para combaterem esse problema
então Vamos explorar como a
biofortificação Agronômica que é
basicamente a adição de minerais e
vitaminas aos fertilizantes pode
aumentar a densidade nutricional de
várias culturas uma revisão sistemática
recente analisou 47 estudos publicados
entre 2012 e
2022 descobriu que a fertilização com
micronutrientes como zinco selênio
cálcio ferro e vitamina C A e B9
tem sido bem sucedida em diversos tipos
de
culturas Mas será que essa técnica é
realmente eficaz e condições de campo e
quais são os fatores que poderiam
influenciar o sucesso da biofortificação
Além disso Será que essa abordagem pode
de fato contribuir para reduzir as taxas
de nutrição do mundo então vamos
discurtir esse vamos discutir esses
tópicos esses pontos apresentando os
principais resultados e limitações dessa
estratégia
promissora Então essa revisão
sistemática mostrou que a fertilização
com micronutrientes tem sido bem
sucedida em aumentar a densidade
nutricional de várias culturas
hortícolas como Folhas Verdes tomates
cenoura uvas e ervilhas os
micronutrientes já foram falados Mas
vamos falar de novo zinco selênio ccio
Ferro vitamina C A e B9 então um estudo
conduzido em 2018 na China demonstrou
que a aplicação foliar de sulfato de
zinco Aumentou significativamente a
concentração desse Mineral em brotos de
feijão já outro estudo de 2020 no Irã
verificou que a fertilização com selênio
elevou os níveis desse nutriente em ál
Especialmente quando aplicado via sola e
foliar no entanto é importante ressaltar
que a maioria dos estudos testou a
biofortificação Agronômica em condições
controladas como cultivo sem solo em
estufa etc assim os resultados podem não
ser os mesmos quando aplicados em campo
ou em larga
escala vários aspectos Chaves podem
afetar a eficácia da biofortificação
Agronômica e precisam ser considerados
entre eles estão variações n condições
de solo de cultivo clima espécie de
culturas práticas agronômicas como
método e de aplicação dos fertilizantes
e a forma química dos nutrientes
sensibilidad dos micronutrientes as
condições ambientais complexidade das
vias biossintéticas dos nutrientes nas
plantas Então para que a biofortificação
seja bem sucedida é fundamental que as
concentrações de nutrientes melhorem nas
partes comestíveis das plantas sem
causar toxicidade para elas ou paraos
seres humanos então alguns estudos
também sugerem que os efeitos sinérgicos
quando V vários micronutrientes são
fornecidos em combinação então por
exemplo o zinco parece melhorar a
absorção de molibidênio do solo e também
do manganês
Então qual é o potencial disso daí né Já
falamos que nutrição incluindo a
deficiência de micronutrientes que é
muito importante porque você sabe que
geralmente os agricultores quando eles
vão repouso nutrientes do solo eles Só
se preocupam com npk né nitrogênio
fósforo e potássio E não coloca os
micronutrientes Então esse problema aí
afeta grande parte da população mundial
essa deficiência de
micronutrientes está ligado também a
condições de
pobreza estima-se que os níveis elevados
de gás carbônico decorrente das mudanças
climáticas isso aí eu fico um pouco
inseguro em relação a esses dados né
porque eu acho que tem um pouco de
manipulação Então mas segundo Esse
estudo houve o aumento dos
CO2 e isso Aumentou a Valência de
desnutrição particularmente em relação a
ferro zinco e
proteínas então biofortificação de
Cultura surge como uma abordagem
econômica e sustentável para enfrentar o
problema e melhorar a densidade de
nutrientes dos
alimentos assumindo maior concentração e
biodisponibilidade de micronutrientes as
pessoas consumiriam e absorveram mais
nutrientes a partir de culturas
biofortificados em comparação com as
convencionais estudos foram feitos com
culturas biofortificados com ferro por
exemplo demonstraram melhora nos
estoques corporais desse mineral e
reversão de
deficiência no caso da vitamina A a
biofortificação com betacaroteno reduziu
a
deficiência no entanto a Organização
Mundial de Saúde ainda não possui
recomendações explícitas por uso de
biofortificação sugerindo que mais
pesquisas são necessárias
portanto apesar de promissora a
biofortificação de culturas ainda
Precisa superar algumas limitações para
alcançar os potencial o ideal é que seja
realizado em conjunto com outras
iniciativas como educação nutricional e
melhoria na segurança alimentar na
sustentabilidade agrícola
bom pessoal vamos responder as dúvidas
de vocês
aqui tem uma pergunta umas perguntas já
aqui acho que relacionado o que eu falei
agora
ã Mas é ao longo prazo esses benefícios
no taixi ou algumas aulas e a longo
prazo quanto tem de praticar pelo menos
aí uns três meses tá
Adriana
é os CAT de katê São bacanas né tem
certa com ta sim você tem
razão Vamos abrir as perguntas
aqui primeira pergunta deixa eu dividir
a tela com vocês aqui
é da
Eliane luteína 20 MG e licopeno 20 MG
para evitar placa deve ser placa de
ateroma
funciona vai ajudar sim mas vai demorar
bastante tempo para fazer efeito tá não
é uma coisa que
seja particularmente rápida tá
isso aí vai ajudar porque são duas
substâncias
antioxidantes
e são carotenoides né luteína e licopeno
mas não é uma coisa que seja rápida tá
vai demorar aí Alguns anos para ter esse
efeito Caro Dr Alan pergunta do Carlos
gostaria de seu parecer sobre as manchas
de veliz que se multiplicam na pele com
tempo o médico americano o poling Thai
não é americano ele é brasileiro já
morou nos Estados Unidos tá afirmou que
essas manchas se desenvolvem nos membros
da mesma maneira como na
pele um fisioterapeuta conhecido Hilton
recomendava vinagre de maçã com alri
ingerir e passar na pele não cheguei a
verificar as modificações
Nada Além disso encontrei poderia
contribuir sobre isso eu acho que o
ponto principal é manter bons hábitos de
vida dormir bem ter uma boa nutrição com
proteína adequada não comer açúcar e
processar as industrializados que
aumentam o envelhecimento da
pele consumir colágeno seja com caldo de
ossos Ou seja você consumindo suplemento
de colágeno vai ajudar um suplemento que
é muito bom pra pele é o ácido
hialurônico e evitar exposição solar
exagerada tomar seus 15 a 30 minutos de
sol por dia mas não ficar mais do que
esse tempo no sol
tá em relação ao vinagre de maçã p
alecrin não sei se vai ser
efetivo pode ser tentado mas não sei se
vai ser efetivo
e mas assim S só vai retardar as manchas
as manchas vão parecer uma hora ou outra
porque o envelhecimento é inexorável Por
enquanto né mas você pode retardar esse
esse aparecimento com essas medidas que
eu acabei de comentar se você tiver ao
vivo a gente pode discutir um pouco mais
sobre
isso Eliane qual seria o suplemento mais
indicado para dar ânimo a disposição
durante o dia eh
creatina elicar itina der ribose com
enzima que é 10 na F de
binol e também nicotinamida ribosídeo
esses são os principais para aumentar
energia ao longo do dia tá
bom
ah vamos
lá Eliane Qual a diferença entre trans
Resveratrol e resitec
resitec é um trans veratrol de alta
absorção tá é um produto relativamente
novo aí que eles aumentaram a capacidade
de absorção do veratrol que é baixa
geralmente essa que é a
diferença tem um PDF sobre isso daí eu
acho que tá até aqui pera aí deixa eu
ver se eu eu acho que até coloquei aqui
num deixa eu conferir isso aqui pera aí
Ah aqui eu acho que eu coloquei
esse PDF aqui do desse
produto tá aqui
ó achei então ele é um produto
patenteado ele é uma forma de liberação
sustentada de Resveratrol tem uma minha
vida mais longa tenho Bio
disponibilidade 10 vezes maior tá então
é um produto que foi desenvolvido para
aumentar a absorção e a disponibilidade
do
Resveratrol
tá essa que é
a vantagem
dele a
próxima pessoal se vocês que estão ao
vivo fizeram perguntas a gente pode
elaborar em cima da resposta Inicial que
eu fiz tá se vocês tiverem sub perguntas
aí ou desdobramentos não entenderam
alguma coisa que eu falei maxol é
realmente melhor que co que10 o
fabricante alega que é porque a absorção
é mesma história do resitec lá que
aumentaria a absorção e A
biodisponibilidade
tá mas isso tá aí é o que o fabricante
diz tá eu eu prescrevi o Max por um
tempo mas eu parei de prescrever porque
ele era muito mais caro e eu não vi
tanta diferença na
prática Marilda quais são os exames
recomendados para controle da hipoplasia
prostática PSA PSA livre PSA livre é só
importante quando PSA
total é acima de quatro então você pode
pedir o trra an de próstata também que
pega a bexiga o trão de rins e vias
urinárias alguns casos PSA tiver alto
tiver suspeita de câncer uma ressonância
prostática com classificação de risco
pades São esses os exames básicos
tá a
próxima
Marilda costumo controlar meus níveis de
glicose no sangue através da hemoglobina
glicada pois se ela Pois se fizer pela
glicos em jejum penso que teria o
resultado de acordo com a minha
alimentação nos últimos três dias não a
a glicose de jejum não vai pegar três
dias a glicose de jejum vai pegar poucas
horas hor tá a glicada pega 90 dias tá e
as frutosamina
pegam algumas semanas tá agora quantas
semanas exatas não lembro agora mas eu
não peço frutosamina de rotina eu peço
glicada glicose e insulina tá então a
Glicemia ela é de horas não é de três
dias não tá sim tem que avaliar as três
coisas hemoglobina glicada Glicemia de
jejum é insulina de jejun os três são
importantes mas dos três a hemoglobina
glicada é mais importante
o
próximo Marilda média de glicos não se
torna muito mais fiel do que glicose em
jejum sim realmente se você puder fazer
uma média com certeza por exemplo tem
aquele aparelho né que é o Freestyle
libre que ele pode medir várias vezes ao
longo do dia que você gruda aquele
adesivo aqui no no braço aí ele faz a
média né faz a média muito mais preciso
sim do que a glicos de jejun uma medida
só Fernanda dores na mandíbula ao abrir
a boca o que pode
ser provavelmente apertamento que ou
bruxismo à noite você tá doendo a
mandíbula na hora de abrir a boca é
porque o músculo da mandíbula deve tá eh
cansado eh fatigado porque você tá
provavelmente fazendo eh tá rangendo os
dentes tá ou tá apertando os dentes é é
o mais provável aí é b você procurar um
dentista para checar isso tá bom ele que
vai indicar o tratamento que geralmente
é o uso de uma prótese dentária noturna
Eliseu pelo que eu disse parece então
que existe própolis Verde em solução
alcoólica e não
alcoólica geralmente o álcool é para
preservação do do ativo el tá é só essa
que é a diferença tá ele dura mais tempo
o própolis vde em solução alcoólica não
é o que um é melhor que o outro essa é
uma questão de preservação dos ativos
vai vai durar mais se for em solução
alcoólica lá no YouTube você disse que
alimentos contaminados com pesticidas
diminui a testosterona verifiquei no
site que esses alimentos aqui são
contaminados com pesticidas aí tem a
listinha aqui que vocês estão
vendo então ao comer esses alimentos
testerona diminui Não não é que ela
diminui é que o receptor de testosterona
fica ocupado tá pelos pesticidas aí a
ação da da testosterol vai ser menor eh
cont tem um pesticida você se refere a
agrotóxico sim é praticamente a mesma
coisa tem algum suplemento que anula os
efeitos dos pesticidas não não
tem você tem que fazer é comer orgânico
você pode usar aquele método que eu já
expliquei em vídeos para retirar eh
parte não é totalmente parte dos
pesticidas ou dos agrotóxicos dos
alimentos dá uma olhada no vídeo nos
vídeos que estão no canal do YouTube
Qual suplemento anula não não tem nenhum
que anula limão não orgânico também é
contaminado com
pesticida eu acho que é menos tá o limão
nesse caso do que por exemplo o morango
que é um dos principais também o tomate
né eles são alguns dos principais aí que
eh eh são mais
contaminados Abacate não orgânico também
não geralmente abacate Eles Não Usam
muito pesticida não é é um acho que lião
abacate aqui são mais limpos do que essa
lista que você colocou
aqui thgo é comum sentir desconforto gás
depois de tomar nac pode acontecer
comum Creio que não porque ele tem um
ele tem enxofre na composição pode
atacar o estômago sim
eh deve se parar nesse
caso depende tá você pode pedir paraa
farmácia fazer em cápsulas
gastrorresistentes e nesse caso aí você
não vai ter mais sensibilidade do
estômago tá
eh o senhor tem experiência com
herban der cerola não não
tenho não sei não conheço esse produto
depois se você puder me mandar o link
para dar uma olhada
Agradeço blon o que que eu sugiro a ser
investigado 32 anos com homem de 32 anos
com mudança cheilo de vida H quase 3
anos bradicardia extc suspeita isso aqui
é tentativa de fazer consulta né
bradicardia extraí e suspeita de
hipotiroidismo subclínico cortisol da
manhã limar inferior temperatura
baixa brá Cardia pode ser um monte de
coisa pode ser metabólico ou pode ser um
bloqueio de de ramo né Aí teria que est
investigando
isso sim os marcadores que você tá
colocando podem ter
correlação bland não dá para te falar
que isso aqui eu já entendi que você tá
tentando arrancar uma
consulta aqui na na Live não dá para
fazer isso tá eh primeiro que seus dados
estão incompletos segundo isso aqui não
é o o ideal pra gente conversar na
durante as lives Eu sugiro que você
procure um médico que entenda de
Cardiologia por exemplo o Túlio Sperb é
um cardiologico integrativo ele você
pode procurar o Túlio Sperb ajudar uma
consulta para investigar isso
daí Eliseu você disse há pouco que os
pesticidas do corpo receptor de
testosterona algum suplemento expulsa
Que eu saiba não eliz saiba não
bem Vamos às dúvidas ao vivo
aqui bem deixa eu colocar
aqui hã
sim algumas pessoas alegam isso que tá
falando O
Eliseu não o ozone não vai conseguir
eliminar todos os agrotóxicos não pode
ajudar mas não vai eliminar tudo não
fiz o tratamento com Metronidazol para
mibas mas continua
emagrecendo não sei tem que fazer
investigação completa para saber o que
que o que que tá dando isso daí
tá não o efeito antistamínico
é evitar que a estamina seja liberada
dos mastos tá não é que ela vai reduzir
o efeito a quantidade de estamina no
organismo mas só vai bloquear a
liberação pelos mastos que é a célula
que libera a
estamina Não não é o único momento é
onde tem pico de testosterona mas não
quer dizer que é o único momento
não não tava me referindo ao ao zoom de
metileno como uma solução para qualquer
doença isoladamente tá mas se aplica a
autismo também
eu eu não tô entendendo porque que você
tá fazendo essa comparação de óculos e
filtro azul com ficar no escuro
Eliseu não faz sentido essa
comparação se você vai você vai usar o
óculos de filtro azul porque você tá
trabalhando com alguma coisa com uma
tela ou um computador ou um um celular
se você não tá mexendo com computador
celular e você evita a luz a a luz
intensa ou seja Digamos que você de 8
horas da noite você não vai mexer com
computador não vai mexer com o celular
não vai mexer com nada certo você vai
reduzir as luzes da sua casa então não
tem por você usar o óculos de luz azul o
óculos de luz azul é justamente para
é obrigado a mexer com essas coisas à
noite então essa comparação que tá
fazendo não faz muito sentido
Eliseu
tá tá bom então se você não precisa
mexer com o computador à noite não use o
filtro de luz azul simples assim
e tente ficar uma duas horas no escuro
se não puder ficar paciência
mas
tá essa comparação não tá fazendo muito
sentido para mim que você
tá perguntando
Aí sim el tem vários alimentos que
eles são problemáticos quando a pessoa
tá com liqu Gut e ela melhora do liqu
gant ou porque curou infecção ou porque
retirou glúten o leite e esse alimento
que antes tava passando pela barreira
para de passar pela barreira tá isso
acontece
sim
ah isso é muito variável pesso a pessoa
dizer is é muito variá de pessoa por
pessoa não dá para te dar essa informar
não mais perguntas
pessoal per
e os pigmentos do da tatuagem ficam
indefinidamente A não ser que eles sejam
removidos
tá não Mercúrio Só se você quebrar
lâmpada você vai ter contato com
Mercúrio não vai a luz da lâmpada não
vai transmitir Mercúrio para você
não difícil dizer isso Eliseu pode ser é
uma combinação de V as coisas até porque
mesmo que você não tenha contato com
agrotox você vai ter contato com ar
contaminado com fumaça de carro de de
indústria você vai ter contato com água
contaminada né então difícil dizer isso
se se o agrotóxico é é o mais é a maior
fonte é uma das maiores Fontes
ã tábuas de cortar de plástico é troca
por de vidro a melhor que tem é de vidro
Porque a madeira ela acumula na ranhuras
bactérias tá C de ossos quando se come
de forma diária precisa mesmo Comer
muita
proteína então o calo de ossos ele vai
dar proteína e vai
dar
é eu não sei se entendi essa pergunta
não caldo de osso é maneira de aumentar
o seu consumo de
colágeno
certo agora agora pode ser que
dependendo da quantidade de proteína que
você come fora o causo de ossos pode não
ser o suficiente ISO vai ser muito
variável quinha tá
bom
ai vamos
lá quase 40
minutos eu vou ficar até 40 minutos e
vou sair tá pessoal
eh
Manuel quando a pessoa tem gastrite não
absorve vitamina 12 existe uma gastrite
uma gastrite atrófica que tem assim
deficiência grave de B12 tá
eh na verdade não isso acontece sim
principalmente com a gastrite
atrófica que é uma gastrite autoimune aí
tem deficiência de B12
bem mais 30 segundos eu tô saindo tá
pessoal excesso de vitamina B12 é
prejudicial é e não é porque na verdade
ela é eliminada o excesso pelo organismo
Mas pode acontecer intoxicação mas é
muito raro
e isso lingual também você pode usar o a
vitamina B2 de forma
sublingual aprendi que a glicina que sai
do Calo osso precisa de muita proteína
Não entendi isso não viu se você achar a
fonte me
mostra bem pessoal Muito obrigado aí
pela participação de vocês um abraço pro
Manuel praquinha para Eliane pro Manuel
Desculpa falei Manuel duas vezes aqui o
Eliseu abraço a todos vocês aí que estão
participando ativamente ao vivo nós nos
falamos na semana que vem um grande
abraço um beijo no coração de vocês
vocês são Fera